♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Hi, my name's Keaghlan Ashley,
I'm here today with Matthew,
and we're gonna turn him
into the Night King
from Game of Thrones.
So, the Night King is obviously
a very elaborate
prosthetic makeup.
It's definitely a pretty,
like big undertaking
for a Halloween costume.
But if you're interested
in doing something like this,
these are all prosthetics that
are available on the market,
and you can purchase it
and do it yourself.
We're gonna start out
with a bald cap,
we're also gonna get him into
some contact lenses,
which is gonna be
our first step.
We wanna make sure
that the lenses are in,
so he can get adjusted
to them, as well as, you know,
we don't have to put 'em in
when the makeup's already done.
So Matthew, I'm gonna go ahead
and have you
-pop those contact lenses in.
-Alright! Let's go.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
Awesome, Matthew!
Those look great.
So now, we're gonna go ahead
and get started.
The first thing you wanna do
is prep your skin.
You wanna make sure there aren't
any oils on the skin.
The first thing that we do
is we take a...
astringent or a toner,
and just kinda knock back
any oils on the face.
Now, I'm going in
with a skin protectant
called Derma Shield.
This is just gonna create
a nice little barrier
between the prosthetic
and the adhesive and his face.
So the next thing up
in our process
is we're gonna do a bald cap
on you.
When you do a bald cap,
you wanna make sure
that you bring the hair down
as tight as possible.
I like to use a product called
XXXX, but gel
or any other type
of hair product will do.
So now I'm gonna go ahead
and put a bald cap on you,
but before we get too ahead
of ourselves,
why don't you go ahead
and take your shirt off,
we're gonna do a prosthetic
that'll probably stop here,
and so it'll be easier to do
that now than later.
I'm gonna be using
a medical grade adhesive
called Pros-Aide.
This is an acrylic-based
adhesive.
It's a lot better than something
like spirit gum,
it'll last a lot longer.
So to make this process
go a little faster,
I'm gonna bring in my assistant,
Cali. Come on in.
Hey guys!
KEAGHLAN ASHLEY:  So to really
take this look to the next level
we're gonna go ahead and use
some full-face prosthetics.
These are prosthetics
by Morphstore,
they're a company based
in Florida but you can
get them online
and you can order them
and have them shipped to you.
These are an awesome way
of making your Halloween costume
take it to the next level,
if you don't have these
or you're a little intimidated
by these,
you can also do this look with
a face paint, it's totally fine.
Now that we've got
the face piece lined up,
I have these horns
that I picked up.
It's gonna be a little bit
more inspired Night King,
but these are just generic,
little devil horns
you can pick up online,
they're by Rubber Ware,
the same company
that makes these ear tips.
And these are a great way
to, um, add...
just some quick,
little horn action,
like the Night King has.
While Cali's blending I'm gonna
go ahead and apply his neck,
that way it'll line up
right underneath his chin.
When you're working
with Pros-Aide,
the thing you wanna remember
is as long as this adhesive
is a bit shiny,
you wanna make sure,
like, you wanna powder it
to lose that shine.
It's always gonna be tacky
until you powder it.
And so I just took a little bit
of translucent powder.
You can use baby powder
in a pinch,
and you just wanna powder
those shiny spots.
This piece is gonna absorb
any product unless you seal it.
So, what I typically
like to do
is take a product called
PAX Paint.
PAX Paint is the same Pros-Aide
adhesive,
mixed with a little bit
of acrylic to tint it.
Um, if you don't have that,
you can just use straight up
Pros-Aide and coat
the prosthetic with just
solid Pros-Aide,
and then move onto your paint.
I'm gonna go ahead and take
a water-activated paint.
this is a Kryolan Aquacolor,
you can buy this at any
kind of makeup supply store.
These are awesome,
especially if you don't wanna do
any kinda heavy duty paintwork.
These you can do straight
to skin,
they're like, I said,
water-activated.
My personal preference
is to paint using a sea sponge.
You can buy these at any Target,
Walmart, if they've got
an art supply section.
Now that we've sealed
this prosthetic in,
then we're just gonna go ahead
and sponge
this Aquacolor all over
the face.
So now that we've got this nice
kind of off-white based tone,
I'm gonna go ahead and set
the Aquacolors
with this awesome proSEAL
by European Body Art.
Um, it's just gonna help seal
all that paint in,
so that when I lay other colors
down, it doesn't get lifted up.
Now that I've got the base
toned down and sealed,
I'm gonna go in with some darker
blues and grays and blacks,
into some of these crevices
and just bring it
more to that Night King
aesthetic that we can recognize.
I'm using an alcohol-activated
paint by European Body Art,
and I'm just gonna go ahead
and run it through my airbrush
and start bringing this
together.
And I'm just gonna--
with my airbrush,
follow along the prosthetic
and kinda bring
this texture up into
the bald cap.
He's got a lot of really fun
kind of...
texture and anatomy in the head
as well,
so I'm trying to replicate that
using
the airbrush and some paint.
All these techniques
you could do
with hand painted
and body paint as well.
I'm gonna switch back
to the alcohol paint
just to kind reinforce
some of the colors.
I like to layer...
both hand painting
and airbrush techniques.
Gives it...
a little bit more
of a realistic feel to it,
it doesn't feel so...
for lack of a better word,
airbrushy.
I'm using an alcohol-activated
palette.
I'm gonna go in and just
kinda detail.
Get into the crevices
that I can't...
get in with my airbrush.
Using kind of a navy blue.
There's not actually a ton
of blue in the Night King makeup
but I want to give a little hint
of that snow.
A lot of the blue that you see
in any of their shots are...
more camera
or surrounding-based.
Using more of a...
off-white tone
and just kinda going in and...
hitting some highlight points.
Now I'm taking just the two
liquid alcohol paints.
And adding a little bit
of alcohol to that,
making it a little bit
of a thinner mixture.
That way I can fill it into...
some of these gaps.
It'll fall into the cracks
and then I can just
wipe away the excess.
I'm gonna get
a darker blue cream out,
so I can get right up to
his water line.
Always want to use a...
cream around the eye area.
It's just safer
and more comfortable
than using an alcohol paint.
And you don't want to use
a water-based paint
around the eyes because...
if they tear up,
it'll just kinda wash away.
Just hitting it with
a little bit more sealer,
just to kinda melt
the paints in together.
Okay Matthew,
are you ready to get into
your White Walker wardrobe?
-Yes, I'm excited.
-Alright awesome.
-Let's get you fitted.
-All right.
Hi, my name's Keaghlan Ashley
and thank you so much
for watching my transformation
of Matthew here
-into the Night King.
-Yeah, thanks so much.
This looks incredible.
And thanks for watching me
become the Night King
from HBO's Game of Thrones.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪